square from what i remember
but we
do have
a game uh that is of import that has
ended and we have fabiano caruana in
studio with us right now having drawn
the game after a tremendous struggle
first of all fabi
you came into this round with the chance
that you couldn't have dreamt of after
round six and then the opportunity
presented itself and you knew that there
were two draws in the other games as you
were actually playing when that happened
that moment when you realized that games
were drawn what were you thinking
yeah i thought it was a great situation
um i also thought i had a very pleasant
position
um i mean something went wrong for the
opening for him i think he should have
taken on f3 but he he allowed me to get
e4 it looks like
the best that i can hope were from his
line
and yeah it looked very pleasant but i
obviously misplayed it
um
probably his queen f3 and all this stuff
was
uh was not great
yeah it looks really nice after taking
e5 i thought i should have a large
advantage
um
but should be eight maybe there was
something better than queen f3 i assume
white has some way to really put the
pressure on
yeah
b3 did you consider knight d3 instead of
knight takes d7 like not trading any
pieces yeah but then after knight b6 i i
thought it would be less than in the
game
okay um the double pawns are not a huge
issue because b5 will come maybe i mean
bite is still better here but
but i preferred
what i did
so the game continued
the
position we're intrigued by
a huge position that's going to occur
in the game oh well here's what we're
going to we're going to get to
when he sacrifices on e5
first it wasn't necessary were you
shocked by the sacrifice no i was
expecting it um
i thought it was very natural i i kind
of liked my idea to play f3 because
uh he wants to take on e4 and queen e4
queen of five and then my d-pawn becomes
very weak
the only downside to this idea is that
he can
sack the queen like he did
well he also we know he also had the
move c5
c5 one here now dc
and uh rook takes and then queen d4
oh yeah i thought maybe this is uh
holding
but
um
yeah it's probably holding but it wasn't
my main concern
um i thought maybe i'll have some minor
chances here but what what he did gave
you major chances when he took
and you were very close to winning this
game as we go down the variation and we
were all surprised as there's one move
that we were calculating and we're going
to get to it momentarily uh right
here
you played rook c1 c5
you moved e6
you did not play why not
yeah i burned all my time um mainly
because most of my time was based on
most of my calculations was based on a
blunder yeah e6 rookie 3 and i guess um
sorry rook gt rook e to g3 sorry is uh
is forced
uh and rook c5 i wasn't um this was one
one idea i had because
um now if he has if he plays rook g5
then e7
should be very strong
um but i thought first he'll give a
check
king e2 and now rook g5
and if e7 the point is now rook f5
ef rook g2 now he has his check
king
somewhere attacking they're working on
bishop e7
um and by the way this game was finished
in a draw the game between tahitian nova
and cervantes that would just
congratulations to begum yeah that makes
second
take second place sorry uh fabi please
oh sorry um
yeah queen of fate i
i wasn't so sure about this but uh but i
figured
after i played rook d1 that this must
must have been the right way
um
it is a very confusing position
and and yeah i um
yeah this e6 was based on a blunder and
then at some point i got low on time and
panicked
um
e6 or rook d1 rook d1 and e6 this whole
whole concept
we were also considering b2b3 it's just
kind of one of those funny positions
where
where black is so tied up you really
can't move
b3 also on your agenda or
calculation he'll play rook g3 rook c5
and something similar except the pawns
on e6 right that's on e5 which isn't
necessarily
a bad thing
um
yeah to be honest there was there were a
bunch of options and i
i didn't really have enough time
30 minutes
30 minutes for the second time control
in this position is is uh not
not really enough to be honest um
and in the end did you have rook g2
instead of rook shoe one
it looks like a draw still with king f3
yeah rook f2 king king e3 well king e3
then rook uh f1
i think that's not what i want
um
but i ha i was going to play king g for
bishop e7 rookie 7 i i assumed
it's probably a draw but i was a bit
worried
i mean i'm the one who has to
prove the draw here yeah right exactly
um but i i guess it should be a draw
yeah
i don't know fabby you
like you say
i still have this okay so it would be
exactly the same which moment here right
here
iii rook f1 f6 and goes into the same
variation rookie rook king e3 rook f1
and now f6 deflects the bishop
and so now
and if you take with the bishop f6 you
have kingly too perfect thank you
we
in the game fabby
yeah no no that was because five we
played f7 sorry yeah i don't understand
why i played f7 to be honest
we
thought it was a great move actually
what
um well
i can just go for the exchange um
we were worried that that might be a bad
position for you though no i don't think
so how we were we were worried about
rook d8 yeah bishop f6
yeah uh queen
take
take take
and bishop a3 i think yeah like let's
say brook rook to c8 or something um
because the c pawn falls
so i'm
yeah but this is i mean i got two
connected passers over here
but the king will cover them just
kidding oh you mean like just bringing
your king over to the
king side something like this yeah
i think this is just a draw
wow
i don't think black has any any winning
chances and also white
doesn't have any winning chances okay i
mean if anyone's playing it's white but
white's not really playing this okay uh
and instead i played f7 which is
a slightly dangerous rook end game
although it's a draw
but i just can't explain this decision
um
well it all looks like a draw at the end
missed opportunity there for you you've
got a playoffs tomorrow which i'm sure
you would have said give me the playoff
five rounds ago
at minus one you now play wesley and sam
seveon
your thoughts about that
i don't even know how it works with
three players uh is it is it a
tournament format well now that you
asked glad you did
because our producer is ready to tell
you what you're up against you can see
what that looks like usually they have
it on the spot there we go three or four
players tied for first it's a rapid
round-robin game in 10 with a two-second
delay
and if your two players are still tied
you go to two-game blitz match with game
in three with a two second delay three
players still tied in your case then
it's back to a blitz round robin you
guys are going to keep us here all day
hopefully not but that's what you've got
ahead of you
how's your 10 minute game
oh it was 10 minutes right yeah very
good you just read it too
i was comprehensive
yeah i feel pretty comfortable with
in that format but um
but i don't know i'm right now too tired
to think about it it's it was a tough
game and
a tough tournament
all right well amazing comeback so far
you still got to boar to seal the deal
congrats and we'll see you tomorrow
thank you see you tomorrow fabby oh
we'll be bright and early oh very eager
i'll be back tomorrow but i think that
this has come back regardless of the of
the tiebreak outcome what fabi achieved
with four out of five in this